hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun problem that was emailed to
me
we begin with a square and a point in
the interior of the square
we'll draw four line segments from this
interior point
where each line segment connects to a
midpoint of one of the square sides
now we've divided the square into four
regions
the area of the south west region is 16
square centimeters
then going clockwise the area of the
next region is 20 square centimeters and
then 32 square centimeters
the question is what's this final area
this diagram is not drawn to scale
and it was distributed with the tagline
that you should be able to solve this
i thank rio in romania for emailing me
this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so key principle in this problem is the
formula for the area of a triangle
which is equal to one-half
the base times the height
so if you have a right triangle where
one of its legs is the base and the
other leg is the height
the area of this triangle is one half
times the base times the height
but this is true for any triangle it
doesn't have to be a right triangle
so all of the following triangles
actually have the same area because they
have the same dimensions for the base
and the height
so how can we use this principle to
solve the problem
we'll go back to our diagram
now connect the inter point to the four
corners of the square
this is going to divide the square into
eight different regions
i'll color code these regions to make it
a little easier to keep track of the
areas
now focus on just these two triangles
which are along the bottom side of the
square
triangles with the same base which is
half of the square side
and the same height which is the
distance from the square side to the
interior point will have the same area
because they have the same dimensions
for base and height
so these two triangles will have the
same area and i'll label the area as a
we'll do this for all of the sides of
the square
we'll consider the next side of the
square
because these two will have the same
base and the same height these two
triangles will have the same area
and i'll label this area by the variable
b
we'll do the same thing for this side of
the square these two triangles will have
the same area and i'll denote it by the
letter c
now we continue to the fourth side of
the square and these two triangles will
have the same area and i'll denote this
area by the letter d
now how can we solve for the unknown
area
well let's take these variables
with the given information
a plus b is equal to 16
b plus c is equal to 20 and c plus d is
equal to 32 and we want to solve for a
plus d
how can we do that
well notice that the quantity a plus b
plus the quantity c plus d is equal to
the quantity b plus c plus the quantity
a plus d
in other words the sum of opposite areas
are equal
so we know three of these areas so we
have 16 plus 32 is equal to 20 plus the
unknown area of a plus d
we then solve that a plus d is equal to
16 plus 32 minus 20 which is equal to 28
and that's the
answer now if you like this problem and
wanted a little bit more of a challenge
i previously discussed a challenge
problem for talented fifth graders in
china
we have a parallelogram abcd and you
need to find the area of the red
triangle
remarkably one student solved this in
under a minute and it uses the same
principles that i described in this
video
did you figure out this square problem
thanks for watching this video
these math videos inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they've already accumulated over 100
million views
i believe as society truly valued
mathematics we'd have millions of
subscribers and billions of views
so please help
you can subscribe for free to get the
newest videos
watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos which is the best way
for more people to discover this channel
you can email me a puzzle or map topic
at presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can also
support this channel financially
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description they're
great for gifts and you can also support
this channel on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support